Mike Tirico thrilled to spend my Sunday
nights on football night in America with
these guys Super Bowl champions Rodney
Harrison Hall of Famer Tony Dungy guys
it's a great long-standing tradition on
football night in America that we're
starting right now if you're the Super
Bowl it's your city in the background to
talk about the new upcoming season
so Philadelphia will be center stage as
we get the season kicked off what's good
division by division can anybody in the
East beat Philadelphia
I'd like to New York Giants I do I like
the New York Giants serious I really
like the New York Giants I think with
the addition of say quantum Berkeley I
think that rejuvenated Eli Manning I
think Odell Beckham he's gonna stay
healthy and and be terrific I think that
defense has a lot of talent on it
obviously last year it was a
disappointment but I like to New York
Giants
I think Philadelphia wins it again okay
in the NFC North map Patricia the former
Patriots defensive coordinators the new
head coach with Matthew Stafford on the
offense in Detroit Aaron Rodgers is back
for Green Bay they're excited about
Mitchell true Biscay and Chicago but
Minnesota has so many pieces are they
the team to beat in the north they have
a lot of talent they've got a great
defense I usually pick with defense but
I think of Aaron Rodgers as healthy
Green Bay wins that division I
definitely agree with Coach Green Bay
and Rodgers they added some pieces on
the defensive side some young guys Jimmy
Graham I agree coach south is loaded
three teams in the playoffs out of the
NFC South last year could be again cuz
New Orleans is still good Carolina's
still good and it Lent is the one team
in the NFC that's been to the playoffs
back-to-back years they have and I like
Atlanta coach I think they're legitimate
Super Bowl contender I look at the south
and Carolina I'm looking for them to
maybe take a step back New Orleans would
still be a very solid team but I like
Atlanta yeah I do too I think they have
the best defense in the division all
right in the NFC West the Rams so much
buzz so many big names a lot of big
personalities too in the big city of Los
Angeles are they the big team to beat
that's a tough one for me because when
you add all of those players and some
guys who are high paid players but maybe
didn't perform for their last team
they've got a lot of talent there I'm
not sure they want it though I think
they win coach because you have those
players they go there for a reason
they're going there to have success to
win a Super Bowl and I think you know
it's it's not like these guys haven't
been great players I think
come together a you good young
quarterback I think Sean McVeigh has
done a wonderful job
I like the Rams you convinced me I think
they had the best day thank you
over in the AFC you know what's the same
old story Patriots Patriots look at the
Jets in the bills they draft
quarterbacks to the first round
everybody keeps trying nobody keeps
doing is it another walk for the past I
think it is and you look at all those
other teams you talked about they're
still rebuilding everyone still have
question marks when it comes to their
quarterbacks I like the Patriots and Tom
Brady too much consistent excellence
from the Patriots and they've got Tom
Brady they're the best team in the
division
Pittsburgh's been up at the top of the
AFC North for a while something
interesting about Baltimore's I watched
them here in the preseason I remember
John Harbaugh telling me on the field
before the Sunday night Pittsburgh
Baltimore game we're one draft class
away from being good again I think they
might be good again what do you guys
they're excited I was at the hall of
fame game and John told me this is the
best team he's had in the last few years
he is excited but I still think
Pittsburgh wins the division coach I
agree with you I like Pittsburgh offense
I think their defense it's not gonna be
great I look at Baltimore and something
about Joe Flacco I think he's gonna up
his game because of Lamar Jackson but
I'm going with Pittsburgh and then
Roethlisberger so did anybody see
Jacksonville coming and being this close
to getting to the Super Bowl no they
didn't question now Blake bortles
three-year contract extension 26 and a
half million dollar guarantee can he
take Jacksonville back to that great
playoff run again this year I say no I
just I don't believe it I look at the
Houston Texans with JJ Watt back to Sean
Watson he's healthy coach I'm looking at
Houston to beat to win that division I
feel the same way
I love the Jacksonville defense but to
me you put JJ Watt Whitney merciless and
deshaun Watson back together if they
stay healthy
clowny they've got that um I think to
get there and win that division they're
hungry the AFC West is the one I can't
figure my old pal John Burton's back in
coaching after a decade out he's with
the Raiders obviously
Andy reading the chiefs of a new
quarterback and Patrick mahomes Phillip
Rivers keeps going the charges make you
believe every once in a while
Denver I'm not sure what's going on
there who's the team in the West I like
the charges I think they're one of the
most talented teams offense and defense
you kind of look at the Chiefs and it'll
get you excited because they have so
many weapons on offensive side but
have no defense I'm going with the
charges I like the charges whoo
something tells me Denver though they've
got this defense that can come back chub
will help them with someone opposite von
Miller but I just love the way San Diego
came in the second half of the year they
got off to that slow start I think they
believe in their coach and they've got
Philip Rivers the key for San Diego is
just they just need to stay healthy if
they can stay healthy they can beat
anyone in the conference health is so
much rapport a part of it so much of a
factor but as you said to us Tony you
know nobody was talking about
Philadelphia this time last year and
it's their cityscape that stays up but
we'll see who's there next year it's a
great season the 99th season of the
National Football League we cannot wait
to see it get started and we look
forward to having you with us every
Sunday at 7:00 Eastern for football
night in America right before Sunday
Night Football on NBC
you